[Music]
recognize and describe people around you
with seeing AI the thing AI person
channel enables you to recognize people
and to get a description of them
including an estimate of their age and
also their emotion that's really cool
because in that moment in time you can
find out what someone's facial
expression was when you're taking the
photo
the app will guide you to help you
Center the face and then once you've
taken the photo you'll hear that
description let me show you hey Anna it
can you come here
effort hi I'm just going this app can I
take a photo of you sure one face near
table edge for a feed away
say goodbye guidance near top edge so
let's move up a bit
I'm totally take picture button
processing 36 year-old male wearing
glasses looking happy button that's cool
is that accurate I shut up yeah no she
rocked my view
yeah they beard anymore good for him
very nice thank you very much selling it
oh that's really cool the other way I
find this useful is when I actually want
to take photos of my friends so when I
take a photo
I can now know that the face is centered
so my photos look a bit better which is
useful if I'm going to put it up on
Facebook for example I also know that
the people in my photos are smiling
which is R it really nice one last thing
you would have heard that when it's
giving guidance it's just saying the
number of people but how cool would it
be if it told me who the people were
then I could use it to look for a friend
you can actually do that by teaching
seeing AI about your friends you simply
take photos and type in the names of
your friends and the next time the name
will be announced as well I'm here rude
near top edge five feet away
Microsoft logo appears